There are all kinds of situations where
we would love to have more control
over what the brain can do,
so that you have these
choices of what exactly you're taking in,
what you're learning, and where
you're going with that.
And there are also situations where we
simply wish that we could experience more.
Say, for example,
that you would like to be able to perceive
things that we currently can't perceive,
you want to be able to see
the ultraviolet, or you want to be able
to hear ultrasound or what if you wanted
to be able to remember more things
than you normally can remember?
The most exciting part of the future to me
is the potential to achieve
humanistic intelligence.
This idea that the late Marvin Minsky
talked about,
which is being able to create
an environment where we have a symbiotic
relationship with artificial intelligence
and we will see a blurring of our
physical, digital and biological worlds,
and not so much being separate parts,
but as being seamless parts
of one integrated human organism.
It probably will be possible to read out
what's inside a person's brain,
to understand what's there by translating
it into something you can understand,
and maybe even putting it back,
giving it to someone, teaching.
When we make a decision now,
we are under the impression that we are
the ones who are making the decision,
and we make it because we want to make it.
But if our brains are connected
to the net, to the computer cloud
and their algorithms that they are using
are decision making,
well, who is deciding?
We are curious to understand who we are,
and why we think the way we think,
and what is the reason of our thoughts,
our memories, our imagination,
our feelings...
Understanding this incredibly complex
organ, that gives rise
to everything that makes us human.
Everything we see, feel,
hear... our sense of identity
and so given the vast complexity
of the brain, in a hundred billion neurons, you know,
hundreds of trillions of connections,
operating in a dynamic network
that's constantly changing...
It's just a really, very,
very complicated system
for us to study with science.
So, it's a, it's a big challenge,
but one that I really enjoy undertaking.
In the human brain, you have about 3
million km of fibers connecting it,
so it's enough to go around the Moon
a couple of times, just in one brain.
The place in the universe that is
likely the most complex and mysterious,
the place where emotions,
thoughts and memories arise,
that place in the universe that tries
tirelessly to understand itself,
an unsolved enigma.
We don't know and we cannot build today
anything that is even as closely connected
to as what we see in the human brain.
There's one hypothesis that suggests
that what brains are doing, what our
brain is doing is generating
a virtual reality,
a model of the world that is
running in our heads all the time,
this has to do with how ideas that have been
floating around in philosophy for a few
centuries, in particular
with the suggestion by Emmanuel Kant,
the German philosopher,
that the reason why the world on our
minds, our views of the world agree,
is not because our minds
reflect the world, no, no,
it's the opposite, is that the world
is created by our minds,
in other words, that what we perceive
is not out there,
it's in here.
It weighs less than 3 pounds.
It consumes scarcely 20 or 30 watts
of power, and nevertheless,
it's able to make calculations
more complex than a supercomputer.
There are 100 to 1000 trillion synapses,
about the size of a bacteria,
they basically are chemical machines.
They receive an electric pulse and then
they release chemicals.
They hit receptors,
a very complex machinery is triggered.
This results in a change
in the behavior of the neurons,
it causes genes to express,
new proteins to come in,
the cascade of biochemical and biophysical
processes is enormously complex.
If you were trying to describe a
thousand networks of cells working,
I would say that imagine that you are
having phone calls with 10,000 people,
at one at the same time, and the same what
you are doing, everybody is doing,
who is living on our planet, on the Earth,
about 7 billion people.
And when you then try to describe all this
communication that is going on,
of all the 7 billion people.
And then you are meant to that this is only one
10th, perhaps, of the capacity,
and everything is only within your skull,
is restricted to one and a half kilogram,
and this is complexity, in my view.
In spite of 100 years of neuroscience,
we still don't understand
how the brain works,
we still don't have in a general theory
of the function of the brain.
The first reason why
I would argue is critical
to understand how the brain works has
to do with our own
definition as human beings.
We are a mental species,
we are defined by our minds,
not by our bodies,
so we are a very special type of animal,
we don't understand the organ
that generates our minds,
so when we understand how the brain works,
we will be able to understand how our mind
is from the inside, we'll understand
ourselves for the first time.
The second reason has to do
with the clinic, with patients.
Humankind should understand how the brain
works because we need, it's urgent that we help
these patients that have mental
and neurological diseases and we have to
understand the system in order to fix it.
We estimate that possibly one person out
of two to one person out of three in Europe
have some kind of disorder
that is related to the brain.
Altogether, it's maybe up to more than 200
million person in Europe
who have one of these disorders.
And it's also associated
with a huge cost for the society.
The cost of all disease affecting
the brain more, than the cost of
all cancer, plus all cardiovascular
disease, plus diabetes.
And then the third reason has to do
with technology and the economy.
And it is very likely that brains,
not just of humans,
but brains of all animals,
have discovered through hundreds
of millions of years of evolution
ways to compute that could be much more
efficient and powerful than what we're
doing currently with our
digital computers.
So, if this is the case, if we understood,
if we were able to break this neural code
and understand
how the brain computes and what are
the algorithms that are present in our
nervous systems,
we will likely revolutionize computer
science, computer technology, and I
would say the economy at the same time.
The Holy Grail for this will be to create
a much more symbiotic relationship
with artificial intelligence.
As we can see today,
artificial intelligence is moving forward
in leaps and bounds,
offering us a myriad of new ways of being
more productive and more efficient in how
we conduct our businesses and how
we manage our daily lives.
With the introduction of more and more
devices that actually understand the human
and help humans optimize their own
performance, we will have a way to create
a much more a different type
of intelligence, what I would
call humanistic intelligence.
The distinction between the biological
world, the physical world,
and the digital world will just blur,
and we will integrate seamlessly
across all of these dimensions.
A deep understanding of the functioning
of the human brain could bring answers
to great philosophical questions,
such as what consciousness is and how
it is built, or if there is free will.
Concepts such as the inner self, guilt
or even reality could change forever.
We are opening the door to a world where
we will communicate directly
with a computer through thought,
a world where we will be able to share our
thoughts and our emotions
through the Internet.
We can envision a future in which we are
able to read the thoughts of others
and even to manipulate them.
We're building technology to read
the activity of all the neurons in these
brains and to write activity to control
and manipulate the activity
of these neurons in the brain.
And these technologies are necessary
to be able to cure human patients.
But the same technologies,
technology is neutral.
It could be used for good or for bad.
The same technologies to read and write
activity into brains can be used
to decipher what people are thinking or
to influence the activity
of the minds of people.
So you say, well, this is science fiction?
Well, not really.
In the middle of the 90s,
the last decade of the 20th century,
and the second millennium,
a whole revolution in the world
of neuroscience occurred:
the neuroimaging techniques appeared.
So neuroimaging techniques are important
for this revolution in how to learn
and explore the brain,
because it's a nice, invasive
way to get inside the brain.
One of the imaging techniques that had
the greatest impact was
magnetic resonance imaging.
For the first time ever,
we could see the inner functioning
of the brain while it experiences
sensations and emotions.
In fact, functional magnetic resonance imaging,
able to detect the presence
of oxygen in the blood and the brain
has allowed us to discover something
unimaginable years ago.
How different areas in the brain interact
while the patient talks, sees an image,
listens to a sound, or simply thinks.
But if you ask him to focus on one task,
like listening to a sound,
only the region from this specific task,
the auditory cortex, for example,
will have more conception of oxygen.
And this region will
pop up in the contrast,
if you analyze the data, even listening
to sound against non listening to sound.
The reason why we don't understand how
the brain works is not because of its
complexity, but because we've been lacking
methods to study at the right level.
Now, if you think about it,
trying to understand a system as complex
as the brain that has 100 billion
neurons by recording from one neuron.
It's a little bit like trying to watch a movie
in a TV screen that has a million pixels
by looking at a single pixel.
So no matter for how long you study
a single pixel or you study a single neuron,
you will be missing the figures in
the screen and the shapes of the images.
Because they are an emergent property
of the correlations in space and time
between the individual pixels.
We think that neuroscience should embark
on this period of new technology
to develop the method so
that neuroscientists and clinicians will
be able to see for the first time
in the future the activity
of complete neural circuits.
And be able to decipher the functional
meaning of this pattern.
How can one measure the activity of each
and every one of the neurons
in the brain at the same time?
The methods that we and many other
people are using are optical methods.
We use light because light can penetrate
the tissue in a noninvasive fashion.
In particular, the method that I
pioneered is called Calcium imaging.
We used it for the first time to measure
the activity of neural circuits.
Every time a neuron fires, every time it's
activated, calcium comes into the neuron.
So that means if you have these little
calcium indicators,
these fluorescent molecules in all
the neurons, you can directly see who is
firing, who is being activated
in the entire group at once.
Because you see this as changes
in fluorescent that are happening
in different areas at different times.
Thanks to neuroimaging techniques,
we have learned more about the brain
in the last 15 years than
in the whole history of humankind.
The advances already made allow us
to think that in the near future, we will
be able to solve neurological damage.
Diseases like Parkinson's or Alzheimer's,
depression or schizophrenia.
Yeah, I think that the revolution we're
experiencing now is first the birth
and the success of human neuroscience.
We now have fields like cognitive
neuroscience where we use functional brain
imaging and noninvasive brain stimulation
to study the functioning human brain.
And that was, I think, the first step.
From my perspective,
I've been doing neuroscience research for
30 years and this is the revolution now.
But now is the time that neuroscience is
starting to reach into
people's lives directly.
And to me, that's what we
need to have a revolution.
We need to advance from the lab
into the real world.
This is a software application to be
able to control the puzzle box orbit.
I'll first connect it to the emotive
NCIG headset,
and that's now connected.
What we have to do is train two patterns.
The first is a resting state so that we
understand when you want
to control the orbit versus not.
And then the second pattern is to control
what you want to apply
for flying the orbit.
This leap from the lab to the real world
can already be seen in the form
of the perfecting of what belonged
to the realm of science
fiction just a few years ago:
brain-computer association,
the so called Brain-Machine Interfaces,
have solidified this revolution
in the world of the neuroscience.
Well, BCI really just means
brain computer interface.
So anything that makes a connection
between processing going on inside your
brain and a machine, some other device.
Brain computer interfaces can be grouped
as a group of technologies that can help
both from a hardware and software
perspective, able to both decode, process,
and activate the interactions
between humans and machines.
Decoding the brain.
Of course, typical decision would be
a platform that can help us interact
from the brain to the world.
The Brain-Machine interfaces are bringing
great advances in various
therapeutical applications.
Up to now, one of the main practical applications is
the treatment of different pathologies
associated with paralysis.
At the Federal Polytechnic School
of Lausanne, Switzerland, Dr.
José Millán has been working for years
on an ambitious project based
on the development of a brain machine interface
that allows paralytics
to control a robotic exoskeleton
with their minds, thanks to which they
can walk again or move a hand.
The patients wear an electrode helmet
that detects their cerebral
electrical activity.
What we ask people to do at the very
beginning because they need to go through
a training in order to acquire
the capability to modulate voluntarily
their brain signals, is to imagine the
movement that they want to accomplish.
And this requires some time,
because it is not easy to do that.
Our algorithms are capable to discover
which are the areas,
the specific areas that they are
activating and disactivating
at which frequencies this is happening.
And this is the input to our machine
learning algorithms that will build
the model of the decoder that will
differentiate,
opening a closing of the hand, right step,
left step, and so on and so forth.
So, during this training,
people at the very beginning need to
imagine the movement of their own body.
And in many cases, people,
after some training,
and because the fact that as they imagine
the movement of their body,
this is executed via the exoskeleton,
they don't need to think any
longer about their own body.
They think in terms of the exoskeleton,
because the exoskeleton has been integrated
somehow in people's
body schema that we have in our brain.
The possibilities that this technique
offers to these patients have allowed
to a quadriplegic patient to be able
to drive a Formula 1
car just with his mind.
In 2017, Rodrigo Hubner Mendes became the
first person to reach such a milestone.
This opportunity to work
with Rodrigo was incredible.
Globo TV in Brazil created a vehicle,
a Formula 1 vehicle that was completely
controlled just using
the power of thought.
So what they used was our 14 channel epoch
plus headset, measuring electrical
fluctuations from Rodrigo's brain.
He spent a few months mapping and training
the algorithms to understand how he
associated specific thoughts,
whether it be drive forward,
right, turn right, left, or stop.
And then he was able to use those commands
to drive this car completely,
just using his mind.
So no steering wheel, no pedals,
just him inside the vehicle.
This was a very fortuitous moment when
Lewis Hamilton,
who is obviously the world's reigning F1
champion, was in the same
place as Rodrigo in the UAE.
Rodrigo posted a very exciting challenge
for Lewis, which is,
would you like to race me?
Surprisingly,
Lewis accepted the challenge,
so I'm not sure when we're going to start
seeing the two of them start practicing.
But I know that Rodrigo is very excited
about the ability and the opportunity
to race with the reigning world
champion, just using his mind.
Around the world,
a wide variety of projects based on brain
machine interfaces are currently
being developed.
In Boston, the company Neuroelectrics has developed
a technology based on the use of
mind-controlled video games to learn
to regulate brain activity.
Okay, so today we are going to measure
your brainwaves with this device.
This device basically uses dry electrodes
to measure your brain waves like this.
And today we are going to measure your
specific outside brainwaves,
and you're going to be able to control an
object in this screen going up and down.
So I'm going to put you the cap.
Then we are first going to measure your
baseline, which is the baseline of your
brain waves, the level
in which your brain is right now.
So the way we have developed our brain
computer interface is we are collecting
brain signals, for example,
alpha or beta or gamma,
which are different frequencies,
right?
And we are capering your brain or power
spectrum, your brain bands,
to something in the screen, which is,
in this case, a little avatar that goes up
and down according to if your
brain waves are up or down.
So this summary here,
this is going up and down according
to your brain waves and you are
controlling it so you need to focus on it
and keep relaxed and try to control it,
moving it up and down.
The mind controlled video games are
proving to be an efficient treatment
for diseases like depression or
hyperactivity disorder in children.
At Neuroscape a neuro-technological
company based in San Francisco,
they are using these video games
controlled by the mind
for therapeutic uses.
All of our research right
now relies on using
a closer video games
that we've created so far,
just using the performance,
not the cognitive brain computer interface
that's still very much
in the research phase.
And then we apply these
closed loop video game treatments to see
if they can improve attention abilities
in many different clinical
populations, including ADHD,
which is attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder, but also post-traumatic stress
disorder, traumatic brain injury,
depression and autism.
We developed these closed loop video games
that record your performance and use
that data to challenge you
in a very personalized manner.
So, if it's too hard,
the game could back off.
If it's too easy, it can
make it more challenging.
It just puts it right at that sweet spot,
and then the game mechanics target
different neural networks
that we're trying to improve.
So, it could be a prescribable treatment,
just like we currently use stimulants
to help improve attention abilities
in children that are suffering ADHD.
In the last few years,
there has been a progressive blossoming
of neurotech start-ups that are
revolutionizing the way to intervene
in our mental processes.
Nowadays, most of them are focused
on helping patients with different types
of damage or neurological disorders.
However, in the not so distant future,
these companies will end up transferring
all these advances to our daily lives,
radically modifying the way we interact
with each other and even
understand the world.
Investing in novel neurotechnology today
could be the best way to generate
an economic revolution in the future
by the development of this new technology
which instead of biotechnology in the case
of the human Genome project,
now it would be neurotechnology, and this
is something that's starting to happen.
Last year, Elon Musk created a
neurotechnology company, Neuralink.
Brian Johnson, another billionaire, has
created a similar company called Kernel.
So, we started to have some new companies
that are based on the promise that this
new neurotechnologies are going
to be cost and economic revolution.
Emotiv is a neuro-informatics company,
so what we do is we're a platform
that allows us to interface
directly with the brain.
Today it's using noninvasive methods.
So we start from the sensor input.
So measuring the brain activity itself
through to the translation
of the electrical signals from the brain
and then we map those to control
and influence the environment around us.
Look at your brain, Kim.
So you're wearing a 14 channel EEG
and this is just picking up electrical
fluctuations that result from neurons
firing inside your brain.
The brain is made up of billions
of neurons and when they interact,
the chemical reaction just emits an
electrical impulse that we can pick up.
You can see that different parts of your
brain is lighting up depending on what you
might be thinking or whether you're
paying attention to what I am saying.
So, what we're doing here is we're mapping
those electrical fluctuations into a 3D
model of what your brain is doing and each
of the colors represent a different
frequency band, which indicates how fast
the information is traveling from one
part of the brain to another.
Located in Lasanne, Switzerland,
in the center of Europe,
is the headquarters of Mind Maze,
one of the largest neurotechnological
companies in the world.
And our big goals are really to disrupt
industries from healthcare,
so really improving quality of life after
a neurological injury all the way to being
able to help healthy individuals enable
the ability of the brain to learn,
to play, to interact, entertain.
One of those technologies designed to help
the rehabilitation of patients who have
suffered stroke is MindMotion Pro.
It's the first device a stroke or a brain
injury patient sees after the injury,
the first two days when they come
out and they need to recover.
It's one of the first devices that's able
to start training of both
the brain and the body.
So it's about neuroplasticity
tricking the brain.
So we're going to put markers
on you so that the camera can see your
arms while we do some activity.
So it's pretty intuitive.
You'll just need to move your
hand to the start button.
And similarly,
if you move it in the direction that isn't
indicated, you'll see how to correct it.
So let's say someone who has a stroke
cannot move the left hand
and he can move the right hand.
The camera in the Mind Motion Pro tracks
the right hand and puts it
on an avatar on the left side,
and then the brain suddenly says,
Something's happening there,
so I should try more,
it starts activating the pathways
that used to control that hand
and slowly accelerates recovery.
The latest and most ambitious proposal
of MindMaze, the cognichip,
goes one step further and merges
neuro-technology with
artificial intelligence.
Some entrepreneurs are looking
into augmenting our brains so that we can
develop super intelligence that allows us
to collaborate with
artificial intelligence.
It would be a way to reduce the risk
for human beings to become irrelevant due
to the rise of artificial intelligence.
It is the next frontier.
Neuroscience and neurotechnology,
brain technology is definitely
the next frontier.
Now we truly are at the frontier where we
can do some impactful
things with the brain.
So, yeah, neurotechnology is
now really going to kick off.
Ignition sequence, start
654-3210
All engines running.
One of the greatest technological
and scientific milestones in history
was the arrival of man on the moon.
The Kennedy era was one of the periods
of the greatest scientific
splendor the world has ever known.
As a consequence,
an important economy grew around it,
which led in a very short time to
unprecedented technological development.
Ideas are what power our economy.
We do innovation better than anybody else.
And that makes our economy stronger.
We had had many interactions
with the White House Office of Science
and Technology Policy and they had
explained to us that they were interested
in grand challenges for the US government
to pursue any different areas of science
that they thought could really be
of the same ilk as, for instance,
the Apollo moon landings,
a big project that really would allow
the entire US community to get behind
something that would make
a huge impact in science.
They found that great science project
in the Brain Initiative,
a research mega project that Obama
announced in 2013 with the goal
of unveiling the mysteries of the brain.
It's a very exciting moment.
There are many groups around the world
developing new methods,
and this is now leading to a reenergizing
of neuroscience and to the perception
that we can really do it,
that this is doable,
that we can actually end up being able
to record the activity of every
nerve in a brain and decipher it,
and this could really revolutionize
neuroscience, just like the human
Genome project revolutionized genetics.
Very soon after the launching
of the BRAIN Initiative,
the European Union announced its own
mega project, the Human Brain Project.
It turns out that similar initiatives
have been created in different countries.
So there's brain initiative in Japan,
in Canada, in China, in Australia,
South Korea and Israel.
The development of all these projects
could change the scenario of brain
research and lead humanity
to unprecedented advances.
So this is very exciting,
this is just happening.
And I hope that this will provide
the ability to generate
knowledge and send this knowledge
throughout the world into different
countries in a way in which no
one is left behind.
And we're all part of the same
exciting moment in history.
We've started the path to a new world
in which a deeper knowledge of the brain
will radically transform
our human condition.
Brain-machine communication will grow
progressively more efficient and precise
and will open up a vast range
of possibilities for human beings
to benefit from the potential offered
to us by artificial intelligence.
With the introduction of more and more devices,
that actually understand the human
and help humans optimize their own performance,
we will have a way to create
a much more a different type
of intelligence, what I would
call humanistic intelligence.
The idea is that you can create
a myriad of devices and sensors around us
that interface and interplay
with artificial intelligence in a way
that makes humans much more
symbiotic with their environment.
So the distinction between the biological
world, the physical world,
and the digital world will just blur,
and we will integrate seamlessly
across all of these dimensions.
So when you feel confused,
your AI will recognize that and will
prompt you with commands.
If it recognized that you're fatigued
it'll, send a command to bruise a coffee
pot or a message to your phone reminding
you to go out and take a short
walk and stretch your legs.
So you will become integrated with your
environment, and your environment
becomes an extension of your brain.
And I think that type of humanistic
intelligence is really where
we're going to see the future go.
The cognitive capacities of human
beings will be enhanced.
There are experiments by colleagues
such as Roy Cohen Kadosh that have shown
that you can improve numerical
abilities in children
that have dyscalculia, people who have
difficulty in doing arithmetic and so on.
I think enhancement via implants
and things like this is
definitely gonna be possible.
Technologies are going to enable humans
to augment ourselves mentally,
just like holding an iPhone,
we can have access to enormous amount
of information if that comes
directly piped into our brains,
we're going to be able to operate
at the cognitive level above
what we operate at normally.
So they're going to be augmented humans.
So, this could cause major difference
in the society,
can accentuate the difference between
different social groups,
different countries.
And we have to ensure that there's equal
access to all of that,
that there's a principle of furnace
that runs across the application of these
new new technologies and artificial
intelligence algorithms.
It gets more interesting when you can
think about neuroprosthesis
in the cognitive parts of the brain.
So let's take, for instance,
this hypocampo prosthesis.
The patients who are going to be the first
ones to use these devices are going to be
the first people with some kind
of superhuman memory ability.
The very first type of memory ability is
going to be that they can choose when they
do remember something and when they don't,
because they can say, okay,
the experiences that were coming through
at 03:00 yesterday,
I want those to be enhanced.
Brain-Computer communication will make
way for brain computer brain interfaces.
You take what this person has learned,
you run it through the translator
and you give it to someone else's brain.
Or you just want to be able to communicate
through something like telepathy.
You can read out what a person is trying
to say or what they're imaging,
what they're imagining.
And you can try to give those imaginings
or those sounds to someone else.
But you could try to detect
what a person is feeling.
And you can translate that in a way
and then give it to someone else.
So you can imagine this as a communication
pathway that wouldn't just work for words,
but it would work for images,
it would work for feelings.
It would work for anything that we share,
in a sense, where we can say because we're
all humans, we all have feelings
of happiness and of sadness and of pain,
and we have a smell and we have vision.
So you can transfer smells,
you can transfer vision,
you can transfer auditory,
you can eventually,
with enough translation,
even translate knowledge and memory.
Connecting brains is going to be done,
there are definitely hurdles and it's
going to take very important
technological breakthroughs.
I think in the future we will definitely
have very powerful synthetic
telepathy technologies.
It will be possible not only to read
others thoughts,
but also to manipulate them.
Let's think about it a little bit more
about the impact and repercussions of this
new knowledge to society, to humanity.
We can, using mice, we cannot read activity
of every neuron here in the brain of a mouse,
but if you look at the visual cortex,
you can actually read the activity
of a few thousand neurons there.
And we can decipher some of the patterns
of activity as they relate to what
the animal is seeing,
what the animal is looking at.
And then we can go in with optical
methods, with optogenetics, and selectively
change the patterns of activity and fool
the animal into thinking that he's saying
one thing or the other thing
by essentially playing the piano with this
neural circuits in the visual
cortex of the brain.
This is something we can do today,
people could do this
with humans, not today.
We don't have the methods to control,
to read the activity
of many neurons in the brain
of humans and to change that.
But these methods are going to be
developed because we need
them for the patients.
In fact, there's a project supported
by DARPA, by the foundation
of Military Research to build
an electronic chip to record the activity
of 1 million neurons
in a human, in a human patient and to
stimulate 1000 neurons at the same time.
And this is not science fiction.
This is something that's
being built as we speak.
In fact, we're helping to build them
because they need to use
this for patients.
And this could be in the
clinic in four years.
A whole new world of opportunities
is opening up before our eyes.
A world where we will have the ability
to coevolve with artificial intelligence.
There is even a hypothesis
that in the distant future we won't
need our biological structures.
If all we are are our thoughts,
our memories, our emotions, our whole
self can be transferred into a computer.
Our biological bodies will
no longer be necessary.
So now we're getting into the more far
future science fiction aspect
of this whole endeavor.
There's a science fiction
term called mind uploading.
What it means is that mind or who we are,
is they no longer dependent
on the biological brain as such,
you still need a brain,
there's no such thing
as no device running your mind.
But it could be all sorts of devices.
It could be a device that is better suited
for, say, for example,
living in space or living on another
planet or living underwater
or something like that.
So when you get to a far future where
the technology of whole brain emulation,
which is really the more scientific
concept, what is it you're
actually doing here?
You're trying to emulate what's going
on in the circuitry when you have that,
then you can start thinking about
the personal and social
consequences of doing that, which is
really what mind uploading means.
It's a very philosophical term in a sense.
Like what happens if you can take who I
am, my mind and move me to something else.
So many things are then
potentially possible.
You could make backups of your mind so
that if something happens, you can
restore and it's not as devastating.
The knowledge we have acquired in recent
years about the brain has
given us possibilities
until recently
considered science fiction.
We're advancing at very high speed.
We can't know where a deeper knowledge
of the brain will lead us,
but it's in our
hands to steer it in the right direction.
It's critical to have
guidelines, ethical guidelines,
for the development
of these technologies.
We propose to add to the human
Universal Declaration of Human Rights,
new rights to protect
individuals from the abuse
of neurotechnologies
and artificial intelligence.
So this is what we call the neurorights,
and they have to do with protecting
the mental Privacy of people.
So this is our first one.
Not just the data Privacy of our phone,
no, the mental Privacy, our thoughts,
and even worse, our subconscious thoughts,
things that we don't even know,
we're not aware of knowing them.
Those should be protected,
this is the ultimate human right,
our mental privacy.
We should also have protection as we
connect ourselves to computers
through brain computer interfaces.
Look at the effect that connecting us
to the Net through our iPhones
has had in our culture.
Well, imagine if that connection could be
direct through some brain computer
interface that could be maybe
wireless and non-invasive,
that could happen in the future.
So, this is going to affect our
sense of identity, of who we are,
we need to protect the sense
of identity, the I, the self.
This is something that humans never
had to worry about in the past,
no one ever had that problem before.
Related to this is also our
sense of agency or free will.
It could be someone who wants to actually
change the way you're operating.
So that's another fundamental
right that has to be protected.
So, these are the neurorights.
Now we have to convince
the leaders of the world,
the leaders of the society,
that this is a very important issue.
We're discussing the future of our
society, the future of humankind,
and that we have to make sure that these
technologies, which are so powerful
and they could cause so much good,
not just in patients, but among ourselves,
we'd be able to finally
understand who we are.
It's like a new Renaissance that these
technologies are not used against us.
We have to be vigilant,
and we just have to put this ethical
framework in place so
that this doesn't happen.
This understanding is just going to give
us the tools to develop in many different
directions, to explore in many directions,
and also to be versatile and adaptable so
that maybe the human species has a really
long term future, not the kind of future
where it works for a while, and then we're
not adapted well enough, and that's it.
But a really long term future.
That's what I'm hoping that this
could ultimately lead to.
I hope it could provide us with the tools
to have basically what you might
call another Cambrian explosion,
where the new species develop in all
kinds of directions, except it's us.
It's the human species deciding that we
want to try out this direction,
try out that direction, and so forth.
Science can change the world.
It can change society.
It can change the course of history,
and I can do that for good or for bad.
It's up to us to make sure that it
goes in the right direction.
We've entered a new age,
the age of neuroscience.
An age in which the way we experience
and feel the world will radically change.
Welcome to the world of tomorrow.